vendredi dernier tf1 diffusait un nouvel
épisode de koh lanta un numéro qui a
très bien marché auprès des
téléspectateurs 5,4 millions de
téléspectateurs
cet épisode a donc été marquée par
l'élimination surprise de bertrand kamel
le candidat décédé en septembre dernier
d'un cancer
le très apprécié et aventurier a quitté
le jeu suite à sa défaite dans une
épreuve d'immunité
regardez l'élimination balle se jouer
entre bertrand kamel et dorian stupeur
duel entre deux hommes forts de cette
aventure
deux personnalités l'un des deux va
devoir quitter le jeu reste une pièce à
récupérer pour dorian il en reste 3 km
calmont berd dans le calme
[Musique]
pour rester dans l'aventuré orient
d'eads a malheureusement perdre aucun
mail vous êtes éliminés et oui éliminé
direct moi ça c'est une épreuve je
serais devenu mauvais que c'était pas
que je peux devenir fou alors
l'élimination directe de bertrand car
elle a été vécu comme un choc par les
autres candidats
juste après l'épreuve certains d'entre
eux n'ont pas réussi à retenir leurs
larmes regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je me sens toucher on est soulagé
de mieux de seconde
quand on voit les deux qui restent
[Musique]
limite j'aurais préféré que ce soit moi
loïc j'ai l'impression que là vous ne
pensez pas qu'on avait plus un possible
ensemble
donc voilà je suis dégoûté qui porte
l'âge en perd deux en l'espace de quatre
jours et je m'attendais pas du tout à ce
que celui qui m'a fait rire depuis 25
jours s'en aille
et doit comme et le candidat apprécier
un bertrand kamel tiré voilà c'est fou
l'émotion qu'il ya après la défaite d'un
candidat oui c'était très émouvant et
évidemment on ne pouvait pas regarder
cette émission sans se connaître les
cieux ça on connaissait l'issue fatale
donc on peut on peut pas le regarder en
oubliant sa et donc du coup à se
rajoutent une émotion supplémentaire à
l'émotion déjà inscrits dans dans
l'émission elle-même vraiment que
c'était un moment très produit alors
vous avez raison il a fait l'unanimité
et des aventuriers de cette saison j'en
ai eu j'ai discuté avec certains y
étaient rassemblées entre eux et avec
d'autres des saisons précédentes donc la
grande famille de koh lanta était uni et
même si ce qui est magnifique c'est que
son flambeau n'a pas été et il n'a pas
été très lors d'un conseil puisqu'il
s'est en quelque sorte éliminé tout seul
moi j'aurais juste sur mon idée de
départ qui était de dire que ça crée une
dramatisation excessive et une mise en
scène de la part de la chaîne y avoir
après avoir fait ses adieux d'autres aux
autres candidats il est parti seul sur
la plage tout seul une image très forte
certains parlent même de la séquence la
plus triste de l'histoire de koh lanta
regardez
[Musique]
la famille prenez soin de vous toronto
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ne voyait vraiment aller plus loin
ces années mes rêves qui s'arrête c'est
très peu de temps avec mes parents je
voulais profiter de cette expérience
pour leur montrer que j'avais grandi
tout est une belle leçon vite
c'est une aventure membres
[Musique]
c'est vrai quand on connaît l'histoire
cette image est allé très très fort oui
moi je suis pas d'accord avec gilles
parce qu en fait y'a rien de prémédité
il dessine là les marchés sur la plage
ce sont les mauvais qui n'a envie de
prononcer à ce moment-là de cette
élimination ça donc je trouve ça
effectivement très beau très poignant
mais juste et pas du tout pas du tout
mal ça alors c'est après des missions
décide tf1 a décidé de rendre hommage à
bertrand km en revenant sur son aventure
dans le jeu l'occasion de redécouvrir la
joie 10 de l'aventurier de revoir quel
point il était aimé par les autres
candidats
regarde le charismatique dijonnais a
donné de la joie et de l'amitié
on va gagner mimi
il était
[Musique]
ces tables d'humeur de da rocha mais
franchement je n'aurais pas pu rêver
mais en
on va clairement des bonnes zones
bertrand club et non franchement c
ces rayons de soleil ici et pour rien au
monde je l'échangerais l'ennui des verts
les verts c'est la galère des moeurs de
claire la misère bertrand kamel le sait
il était aimé la traduction était
formidable sur tous les points c'est pas
facile à gérer c'est très délicat et en
plus de ça j'ai été vérifiée sur les
replays que généralement les extraits
sont découpées et même ça ils n'ont pas
mis l'extrait de laumac parce que
généralement de ces vidéos qui peut être
extrêmement cliquable mais là dont ils
ont laissé l'épisode en entier s'en
extraire l'épisode hommage je trouve ça
vraiment très bien la part des dalles
paix et de téléphone pour répondre à
géraldine j'ai pas dit que c'était
prémédité j'ai dit qu'il ya une
scénarisation une dramaturgie une
utilisation je vais pas dur une
exploitation une utilisation de ce qui
s'est passé et j'aurais sur mon idée
première
c'était une erreur pour moi de diffuser
cette saison parce que quand on le voit
et qu'on sait mais c'est mon opinion
quand on le voit et demande un concert
qui est l'émanation
on a pu aussi découvrir un entretien
entre denis brogniart samir le père de
bertrand kamel chez dernier évoquer le
cancer de son fils est aussi fait part
de son bonheur d'avoir pu découvrir son
aventure regardez un témoignage une
également
bonsoir samir ben sera denis vous avez
vu l'émotion suscitée par le départ de
votre fils bertrand kamel je suis pas
étonné connaissant mon fils et en
connaissant le
l'amour qui donnait aux gens que les
gens du rand
ils lui rendent cet amour là il est
cette terrible maladie qu'est le cancer
on peut le dire qu'il cancer du pancréas
mais il avait un courage du pin début
jusqu'à la fin
il voulait que cette émission continue
pour lui et je vous dis merci de la
sphère continuer parce que c'est grâce à
ces épisodes
j'ai l'impression que mon fils n'est
encore avec moi alors oui valérie mais
cette interview la des manteaux ce que
tu veux dire de pointe en point on s'en
fiche que toi eu droit aux entournures
ce qui est important c est ce que les
parents eux sont contents ou pas est ce
que ça leur a fait du bruit nous parce
qu'ils ont cru leur fils
encore une fois ou pas et est-ce qu'on a
exaucé le dernier voeu de ce garçon moi
je pense que ça a été très triste de
voir pour la famille leur fils quitter l
aventure justement là sur cet épisode
ils ont dû l'attendre et ils ont dû se
dire avec leurs doutes
et c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens qui
ont dit on est en train d'assister à
l'un des moments les plus tristes des
vins saison de koh lanta la france
entière après l'élimination de bertrand
kamal est triste on dirait qu'ils
savaient qu'ils allaient ne pas le
revoir les autres candidats tellement il
était triste alors qu'il a su après
tests il apparaît qu'il était juste une
douleur pendant le tournage avec était
donc il ya déjà très longtemps il ya un
an
il a une douleur mais c'est après bien
évidemment que la maladie s'est déclarée
c'était au moment du tournage oui j'en
ai fait c'est tout sauf une
dramatisation la part de tf1 de cet
événement c'est juste de l'émotion et je
te rappelle quand même que aussi bien
denis brogniart que alexia laroche
joubert productrice de l'émission sera
ce très proche de la famille qui sont
ils sont allés après après l'enterrement
comme ça pour rencontre la famille ce
n'est pas une demande de tf1 de fun de
jouer là dessus c'est même insisté pour
qu'on rende hommage à bertrand guay
alors il ya eu alors il ya un autre
événement aussi c'est autre chose a
enroulé voilà vous montrer un autre
événement qui a marqué et qui a marqué
vraiment d'un autre style c'est un truc
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus sympa qui a
marqué cet épisode c'est l'épreuve de
confort c'est lorsqu'alexandre à la
jeune mère de famille a ainsi pu
déguster tout seul un énorme mais qui a
eu beaucoup de mal à finir et c'est vrai
que koh lanta moi je trouve qu'en ce
moment et ben ça fait partie des
émissions qui valait rien oui c'est vrai
on s'évade avec
les besoins bonjour en gare de
saint-denis regarder
il est rouge
il est vraiment énorme une épaisseur à
l'intérieur alors impressionné c'était
trop là j'arrive dans un étang st palais
tout était trop beau c'est ou moins
jeunes amis s'étaient pas entendus en
dehors de toute une vache qui sait pas
pour vous j'ai beau super que vous êtes
en transit les mois le burger je le
défends sa tête sur koh lanta vous avez
ça savez vous êtes commence à rigoler
mais moi bon castaldi avec ses petits
yeux des siens de gaza ssl jeu maxi avec
son voile s'appelle will fall dans le
compte instagram est le plus exposé
parce que ses photos sur son magnifique
et là on dans des tenues incroyables
chez opéra et son convoi vous êtes un
travailleur et enfin journal celui-ci
attend dinho libre à l'onu non on ne
s'habille pas d'hier elle a déjà précisé
c'était pas du tout libertines c'est
qu'elle n'est pas mariée elle vient
derrière